hi I'm Ken Jeong and welcome back to
dock support now the director to my
right is saying no pressure just have
fun just cuz it got 22 million views of
first time around don't think like that
you know what go the other way around if
this doesn't get Adele like numbers I
will myself doc support to electric
boogaloo let's do this at Lexi alazai
she has way too many eyes and that
name never trust a person with
five eyes I said I always say can you
get sick from flying somewhere hella hot
then back to somewhere cold you know I
really always respect patients that uses
words like hella yeah of course you can
get sick what kind of question that's
more common sense any extreme change in
temperature can have your body react in
a certain way that will cause you to
have your immune response muted and then
not be prepared for the transitory
change in environment booyah it's right
off the top of my dome yo alright next
tack tip Pierce junior says how much is
too much drinking to the point it's a
problem four days a week a drink or two
a day only on the weekends situational
per person can you ask more questions in
a tweet you know what if you have more
than three questions in a tweet you're
an alcoholic
and that's what you are Kip I get some
help you obviously do a lot of day
drinking and day drinking as you know
and some medical fact it leads to
annoying questions on the Internet wish
you the best chuck is shot can someone
tell me well hi I'm sick after getting a
flu shot that's supposed to prevent me
from getting one question mark one
that's actually a very nice question
because sometimes there is this myth
that says you can get I got the flu from
the flu shot that isn't not the case if
you're already having a cold okay
and if you get a flu shot you can get a
little bit sick from the combination of
having a cold and that flu shot but you
cannot get the flu from a flu shot you
have a better chance of having a weaker
flu symptoms II than somebody else who
didn't get the flu shot you should get
the flu shot at Eileen or at I'll see
key on us yeah that's cute
is there any magical remedies for cold
and a runny nose I I feel so unhealthy
for the time being that's actually a
great question and the problem is there
is actually no cure for the common cold
you just have to treat the symptoms
there's actually no antiviral there's no
antibiotic you just have to write out a
common cold and you know that's actually
a very good question so great job Eileen
just work on your at Twitter handle it's
horrible pancake Dan go ask what's
e.coli is that like hard Carlie ecoli is
a bacteria that can cause massive
overwhelming body infection iCarly is
Miranda Cosgrove okay I'm here to
protect Miranda Cosgrove rights which is
I think is why they call it the Miranda
rights ELISA Ashley says does anyone
else get sick when they're really
stressed if so how do you prevent that
well first of all stop cursing in your
tweets okay it does you no
good okay also you can get sick if
you're really are stressed your immune
system gets compromised and yeah it can
make you more prone to get colds look at
me think of me as the ultimate role
model I can do anything I'm a doctor of
an actor I'm a comedian I'm an Instagram
model I can do anything so let me tell
you just be relaxed just be cool
just chill the out be like my
friend Luis here alright he's relaxed
right well she lost his brain then how
do you put a pray back in
at Gomer blog what's your favorite heart
chamber mines right ventricle left
ventricle gets all the attention
meanwhile right ventricles over there
taking care of bidness that's I'm more
of a left atrium gal myself that really
leads into is the Stockton to Malone of
the left side of the heart it it gives
the assist to the left ventricle so it
can go for the dunk it's like the the
old Chris Paul Blake Griffin LA Clippers
if you will relationship that's that
that's the left side of the heart so
left atrium is actually my favorite
heart chamber that's a really great
question
Gomer block at the bode show ask is it
pointless to drink kombucha whilst
taking antibiotic for an ear infection
I'm assuming the antibiotics would kill
the beneficial gut bacteria from the
kombucha
bucho let me just um no I'm not calling
anyone I'm looking at this tweet I don't
really understand there's a kombucha or
kombucha kombucha okay is a pointless to
drink kombucha whilst taking antibiotics
for an ear infection great thank you
that was my wife who's a doctor and the
official answer is I don't know grace at
a fool of my heart says how long should
I go without using earphones after
having a really bad ear infection did
you ever think using those earphones
would cause that ear infection
maybe get a speakerphone or something
let's say you do have a really bad ear
infection which is called otitis externa
that's actually an infection of the
outer ear canal and that's very common
actually with having ear buds you would
probably use antibiotic or antifungal
topical ear drops for seven to ten days
without using earphones so see what I
did there what started out as being
really obnoxious you know I have a heart
alright quite frankly I have a fool of
my heart at so Joe Louis is physical
affection Werth bronchitis asking for a
friend
I mean are you french kissing somebody's
lung I don't know what this question is
look if you're making out with someone
who has a cold you know just uh you know
be advised just be careful you know like
I love my wife and she is always worth
getting bronchitis for and in fact we
wrote that in our vows I'll have you in
sickness and health and bronchitis in
most forms of walking pneumonia at Ben
Duke 78 y'all be peeing a lot when you
should drink or should I see a doctor
I think what he's trying to say in John
Hopkins medical language is um excuse me
I tend to have a lot frequency and
combined with bouts of retention is it
my prostate should I see a urologist in
all seriousness yeah if you find
yourself going to the bathroom a lot
when you drink got ask yourself like
caffeine is a natural diuretic so if
you're drinking a lot of coffee it
actually makes you diurese makes you
urinate a lot but let's say you're
drinking like regular amounts of water
that you normally drink and you find
yourself going to the bathroom a lot
urinating a lot or if there's blood in
your urine no you definitely should see
a doctor it really depends on how much
you drink and what you're drinking and
is that different from your normal
routine of drinking so great question at
shack strife how to avoid being nervous
while checking blood pressure that is
actually a very common cause of elevated
blood pressure in a doctor's visit you
can get what they call white coat
hypertension
I think the key actually is for the
doctor to recheck it again if it's
really abnormally high and it's usually
not very high
maybe you just wait 5 10 minutes and
recheck it again it should be fine at
Ashley Renee 94 says can you lie when
filling out paperwork at the doctor's
office of course you can you should
always lie when filling out paperwork
telling the truth in life rarely does
you any good unless it fits your
narrative so can you lie when filling
out your paperwork not all the time but
you should
what kind of question is that
at Mikkel loo DAF asked does anybody
else forget how to breathe when the
doctor put the stethoscope on their
chest actually you know to be technical
about it
Mikkel you don't forget to breathe or
you die it's like maybe taking a deep
breath inhaling or exhaling and that's
not your fault that should be the
doctors if you forget to do that
the doctor should tell you to take a
deep breath to inhale or exhale at max
yourself out I have yet to see anyone
asks the real questions such as is a
placebo fake if it works dude that's
actually an amazing question there is a
medical phenomenon called the placebo
effect if something may be psychosomatic
in nature if you have a placebo used to
treat that that actually may be
therapeutic so that actually means that
placebo works so that's like a great
great question
at erase ask I have a question for my
doctor friends of Twitter first how
often should I get a tetanus shot second
how often do I know if I have a tetanus
third how often how much is a tetanus
shot first of all you spell tetanus
wrong but I'll forgive you for that it
getting a tetanus shot at least once
every 10 years is very important at
Leigh Marique I cannot stop craving
orange juice do I have scurvy normally I
would laugh at someone who puts four
question marks in a tweet but scurvy is
a vitamin C deficiency orange juice is
full of vitamin C in America in a
westernized country and industrialized
country chances you know scurvy is very
very uncommon but if it's something that
you're really concerned about you know I
would just see oh we just talked to your
physician all right I think we're done
with Doc's support and I just want to
say thank you so much
Thank You Lois sorry I didn't get to
chance to talk to you that much this
time but most of these questions are
really good some of them absolutely suck
and you should be ashamed of yourselves
have a good day
you